[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is the best CS
class you've ever taken?
I've taken a lot
of great classes.
But honestly I think
I really enjoyed
601, which was the Intro
Computer Science course I
took at MIT my sophomore year.
And I really liked it
because it was sort of
built around making a robot.
And every week we would
build an additional thing
onto the robot.
So the first week,
we would just make
it walk in a straight line.
And the second week we would
try to make it turn corners.
And the process of interactively
coding things and then
immediately seeing the robot
do what I just told it to do
was really fun for me.
And probably one of the
reasons why I decided
to stick with computer science.
Definitely algorithms
and data structures.
I went to Harvard for
undergrad and they
had an algorithms class
that was notorious
for being the hardest
computer science
class in the entire curriculum.
People would shake when
they talked about it.
And I remember being so
nervous and intimidated.
But algorithms are
actually quite fun.
There are hard
sometimes, and not
everything came
super easily to me.
But I like the way that
you could sort of come up
with a little recipe
and how to solve this.
And then analyze how well that
recipe works and whether or not
it actually gets
you what you want.
I would say my favorite CS class
was Intro to Python and Intro
to Programming
because that's what
got me interested in a lot of
these algorithms and research
in the first place.
It was definitely
Computer Vision
and was also one that I took
last semesters in CSAIL.
It was particularly interesting
because I could see aspects
that I learned before.
And in the way that
they are practical.
And we even had to design
a camera for this class,
like a pinhole
camera, which made
it particularly interesting.
My favorite computer science
class is probably Intro to AI.
It was taught by Hod Lipson
at Cornell at the time.
And it was really interesting
because I was really excited
about all these
different things, AI.
I want to know, how do you
make a game playing AI?
How do you solve problems
in robotics where
they have to navigate a room?
After about two or three weeks,
I had coded up an algorithm
to solve--
there's this board game
called Rush Hour where you're
trying to move cars
around and you're
trying to get this red
car out of a traffic jam.
And I used to play this
game all the time as a kid.
And after three weeks, I
had written an AI program
to do a search and basically
solve any level difficulty Rush
Hour problem in
less than a minute.
And it was just it
was super empowering.
And I saw all these applications
that I could use this for,
for video games, for robotics.
And that was just
really exciting,
about how quickly
I felt like I was
able to do really sophisticated
tasks after learning
that material.
I took my Introduction
to Programming class
at UC Santa Cruz, which was
taught by Charlie McDowell.
Was my first big experience
into programming.
And I really enjoyed the class
because I learned so much
there, data structures,
programming flow,
and some animation.
So we used processing.
And we make visual images move.
And it was my first experience
really coding anything.
And I really enjoyed that.
So I would say probably
that was my favorite class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]